well america has experienced a
rapid in fact a massive inflation in
genders
at one point biologists were allowed to
determine what biology was and there
were two male and female
now there's agender by gender to spirit
herja we could go on forever
literally forever because the orthodoxy
is that there are infinite genders but
not
everyone agrees some people believe in
science at their peril it turns out lake
engel is one of them he's a student at
indiana university of pennsylvania
in a religion class a class about
christianity
he stated his belief that there are two
genders because again
that's biology and for that he was told
he had to apologize in front of the
class stand silently while they
critiqued him
for education camp stuff blake engel
joins us tonight mike thanks for coming
up
thanks for having me tucker so i don't
know if i was mischaracterizing that you
had this professor called
allison downey who was so threatened
because you disagreed with her that she
tried to get you to sign
some form apologizing for your
unorthodox
non-allowed thoughts and then what
happened
right yeah she asked that i would sign a
document complying with her asking me to
apologize to the class as well as giving
her a written apology
she asked that i would stand in front of
the class in silence
as i apologized and then they would give
any comments
on my outbursts did she say
what specifically she was so offended by
she didn't like the fact that i
disagreed with the
subject being pushed in class being more
than one gender
male privilege uh systemic sexism and uh
mansplaining
what's is mansplaining a a measurable
thing i mean is it like species of
social science studying mansplain what
is mansplaining anyway do you know did
you learn
um i'm not sure i think it's any time my
man speaks really
huh and so it isn't measurable what did
you right i mean it's a it's a species
of dumbness really so but what did you
it's propaganda what did you
say about gender that made her so mad
specifically
well i first reference entities like the
economist who have
debunked the myth of the 77 cents on the
dollar wage gap
and i also stated that biologists don't
agree that there are more than two
genders
they don't believe that there are 72
genders or more across the board
but most of them disagree and she really
didn't appreciate that
so by citing the long-standing view of
biologists the hard scientists
alison downey who supposedly you say
she's a professor
tried to get you to stand in front of
the class and take abuse did you do that
no i didn't i was supposed to but she
really didn't give me a chance
i was given 10 days to comply but the
day after
she asked this of me she decided to push
it on through to the university's
provost office
to then hold a hearing which would
decide whether or not it could be
allowed in class
period why do you go to this school why
does anybody go to the school or any
other school
i mean what are you getting out of this
exactly well i initially went for
athletics my freshman year but that's a
long gone dream now i'm pretty much just
stuck here man i wish i could hire you i
would encourage you and anyone else who
has any experience like this to drop out
and join the workforce it's not worth it
this is a joke it's a bubble and we're
all going to realize that in ten years
like you're a brave man for coming i
appreciate it thank you
thanks tucker